well
hello, how are you, andrés gonzález
with his brief information for today,
friday, august 27, the supreme court of
the united states allows
evictions to resume, blocking the
temporary prohibition of the
administration of the president of b and d,
in court he said that the center for
disease control and prevention does not
have the power to stop
eviction orders during the pandemic at the
state level the moratorium has passed its
expiration date and if you are facing
an eviction order you can request
help for more information visit
our news now page
diagonal dotcom in Spanish
one of the centers that offers help is
the legal aid center which organizes a
clinic tomorrow this will be from
ten in the morning to one in the afternoon at
the surf freeze community center
located near spring mountain road  and
Cimarrón Road if you have questions you can
call 70 2 386 10 70
if you still have questions where you can
get the  a vaccine against cob and we
tell you the clinics that are
offering this service today
there will be one at the harvard
alan departments on harmony near paradise
another will be inside the freemont hotel and casino
from 10 in the morning to 5 in the
afternoon for  a full list remember to
visit our website or social media
las vegas' flights will play their
last pre-season game this
sunday this means they will have to
make decisions regarding
line-ups as they must cut their
roster from 80 to 53 players for
next  tuesday the coaches say
that this will not be an easy task
and the last preseason game will be
on sunday in san francisco the game
against the fort and nai starts at one
in the afternoon the riders will open the
regular season on monday
september 13 against  of the
baltimore ravens inside the li jing stadium
and now we go to see the weather forecast
we will have temperatures
reaching 107 degrees pa  or today with a
totally clear sky however
we still get some smoke
from the wildfires in
california the heat will continue in the valley
with temperatures in the triple digits
until Tuesday next week
there will be a slight chance of drizzle to
from Tuesday that runs
until Thursday have a nice day
greets you at 3 gonzález and this was about the
news now news in spanish